aquí intervalo podemos restringir fx
igual a coseno de x menos y sobre cuatro
para que fx sea invertible y nos
muestran como se ve coseno de x menos pi
sobre 4 su gráfica veamos qué es lo que
significa para una función ser
invertible una función es un mapeo de un
conjunto que llamamos dominio
me presta un poco gruesa el día de hoy
ahí lo tenemos así es que este conjunto
es el dominio mientras que este conjunto
de aquí es el rango el rango una función
mapea un elemento del dominio a un
elemento del rango esto es lo que hace
una función mientras que la inversa de
una función mapa un elemento del rango a
un elemento del dominio eso es lo que
hace la inversa de la función es la
dirección de la función es la dirección
de la inversa de la función ahora
una función no es invertible cuando se
da la siguiente situación se tienen dos
elementos del dominio que se mapear a un
solo elemento del rango aquí tenemos que
ambos elementos se mapean a este
elemento del rango aquí estas dos
representan a la función si este es el
caso no va a ser posible definir una
función inversa pues si esta es la
entrada en la función inversa a qué
elemento lo vas a asignar lo vas a
asignar a este elemento o lo vas a
asignar a este elemento de acá por lo
cual para que haya inversa requerimos un
mapeo uno a uno es decir para cada
elemento del rango hay un solo elemento
el dominio del cual procede una manera
de ver esto es trazando una línea
horizontal en la gráfica de la función y
ver si cruza la función más de una vez y
aquí podemos ver que este es el caso
trazamos una línea horizontal y vemos
que en este caso la cruza varias veces y
por qué se da esto deja de mejor hacerla
en un número que es más fácil de ver
déjame trazar aquí la línea horizontal
porque esta línea horizontal
hasta que no existe la función inversa
esto es así pues para la parte del
dominio que se está mostrando aquí
podemos detectar que hay varios
elementos que mapear al mismo elemento
del rango mapear a 0.5 0.5 si evalúan la
función en este valor de aquí obtienes
0.5 si evalúan la función en este valor
de aquí también obtiene 0.5 y se evalúa
la función en este valor de aquí también
obtiene 0.5 y si se da esa situación que
tenemos múltiples elementos del dominio
que mapear a un solo elemento del rango
entonces la función no es invertible
para ese dominio así es que lo que vamos
a hacer es restringir el dominio para
que si aplicamos esta que llamaremos la
regla en la recta horizontal solo
interceptemos la gráfica de la función
una sola vez revisemos entonces estas
opciones
el primero es el intervalo abierto que
inicia en menos cinco cuartos de pi
abierto en menos cinco cuartos de pie
aquí está menos para un cuarto hacia la
izquierda es menos cinco cuartos de pie
aquí tendríamos menos cinco cuartos de
pi y el intervalo termina en menos un
cuarto de pie aquí tenemos menos un
medio de pie que sería menos un cuarto
de pie abierto va a mostrar un color
distinto para marcar esto aquí tenemos
el intervalo menos cinco cuartos de pie
a menos un cuarto de pie es abierto no
incluye los extremos aplicamos entonces
la regla de la recta horizontal esta
sería la recta horizontal podemos ver
que aquí hay dos elementos del dominio
vamos a ubicar lo mejor que van al mismo
elemento del rango que sería el valor de
menos 0.6 se trata de encontrar la
inversa de menos 0.6 a qué valor iría
iría este valor hoy día a este otro
valor así es que este intervalo no
aplica ahora de menos pick-up y lo voy a
hacer
en este color el intervalo es de menos
api
incluimos el menos pi porque es un
intervalo cerrado a ti y también
incluimos el pi también está cerrado en
pie construimos la recta horizontal y
vemos que no hay inversa hay
intersección en dos puntos de hecho
podemos tomar la recta que ya tenemos
que hicimos aquí en azul y nota que hay
varios elementos del dominio que mapean
a 0.5 cuál sería entonces es inversa de
0.5 no puedes encontrar una función
inversa que maté a un solo elemento el
dominio así es que descartamos también
este intervalo ahora menos un medio de
pi a un medio de pi vamos a graficar lo
se me están acabando los colores
ok vamos a ver aquí tenemos menos un
medio de pi a un medio de pie cerrado el
intervalo veamos este es el intervalo se
ve interesante aquí aquí sí está si está
funcionando pero aquí no aquí tenemos un
problema aquí la recta horizontal
intersecta en dos puntos
tengo dos elementos del dominio que
mapean al mismo elemento del rango así
es que también descartamos este
intervalo me queda una sola opción
espero que estas funciones inicia en
medio pi medio pies intervalo abierto y
termina en cinco cuartos de pie aquí
tenemos pi sería un cuarto a la derecha
de pi aquí termina en cinco cuartos de
pi veamos entonces parece ser que este
si funciona te hacemos las rectas
horizontales para todo el intervalo si
efectivamente para todo el dominio la
intersección de las rectas horizontales
con la gráfica de la función se da en un
solo punto
así es que podemos concluir
para todo elemento del rango que se está
mapeando solo existe un elemento del
dominio del cual procede se cumple la
prueba en la recta horizontal este es un
intervalo válido